hello everyone this is the famous game
from the 2003 linearis tournament garry
kasparov vs team or a job of and the
game is called David vs Goliath because
well Kasparov was world champion at the
time and Rajab was a 16 year old boy
looking for blood and well Kasparov was
a got fourth place in the end and a job
of got last place in this tournament
it was a double round tournament
petróleo won this tournament with seven
points and Kasparov had six and a half
points and got fourth place and it was
probably due to this game this game was
played in round 2 that caused part of
lost lost to a younger job of that cost
him first place and this is the only
game Kasparov lost in this tournament
second game the job of played against
Kasparov they drew so in this tournament
it's one and a half to have in a job of
the favor and it's it's a very
interesting game a lot of people are
saying our job was lost in this game
Kasparov among them but Nigel Nigel
short actually gave young Rajah much
praise for his game but we'll get to
that
so let's see the game because Park has
the white pieces Center a job of his
black efore and east six the fringe
defense the d4 d5 Knight to c3 Knight to
f6 and E 5 the Steinitz variation 937 f4
c5 and knife to f3 we have Knight to c6
Bishop to e3 a6 Queen to d2 b 5 a 3 and
Queen to b6 about a job of a night
Stewie 2 adding more protection to the
d4 pawn and Kaspar a resolve closes the
position with c4 and well the position
on the Queen side is closed now because
power is looking for play on the King
side he goes for g4 wood ideas like f5
our job of plays h5 we have G captors on
h5 rook captures on h5 and now 9th to g3
we're a temple on the rook
rook to h8 by Raj above and not because
part of bushes f5 we have he captures on
f5 Knight captures on f5 and knife to f6
now opening opening up an attack on this
night on f5 Knight back to g3 we have
Knight to g4 attacking the bishop on e3
Bishop to f4 and Bishop to e6 and
Kasparov place C 3 we have Bishop to e7
and Knight to g5 by Kasparov going for
that bishop on e6 Rajah plays a
queenside castle we have Knight captures
on e6f captures on e6 and Bishop to e2
and this is the critical position of the
game probably the most critical position
of the entire tournament as well as part
of his attacking reserves night on g4
he's given him an option either you will
capture this pawn on h2 or you will
retreat with the night on h6 and well
capturing this pawn with knife captures
and h2 doesn't really achieve anything
for black Casper would simply Castle
queenside and well this this Knight is
stuck on h2 he can't go anywhere back so
this wouldn't really be a good idea
so after Bishop to e2 Kasparov knew that
the job wouldn't capture the pond that
he would probably play Queen nice to h6
but the job of plays a very cheeky move
he plays Knight G captures on e5
sacrificing a knight and well you could
see that Casper was disgusted with this
move so what do you do here well for
example the first idea you might get is
captured the night with the pawn this
seems like the most direct move but if D
captures on e5 you resolve has this
option of playing D for threatening to
open up the center and after a queen
sized castle this g5 move is very
dangerous and if Bishop captures and g5
as the Bishop has nowhere to retreat so
Bishop captures on g5 and now T captures
on c3 with an attack on the Queen and if
the Queen goes to e3
to keep an eye on this Bishop on g5
you get bishop
chapters and g5 now pinning the Queen
Queen captures Bishop and now before and
well this is uh this is a pretty
decisive attack for black so Kasparov
definitely decides not to go for this
and well after Knight to g5 you also
have the option of capturing the night
with the bishop so let's see what
happens if Bishop captures on g5 if
Bishop captures on g5 and well for
example Knight captures sunny 5d
captures on e5 Raja has this well option
of playing Bishop to c5 and now
preventing Kasparov from castling if he
castles basically three is coming but
okay this is a black black is on the
attack and Kasparov is a piece up so
this this can be played for white but
Kasparov decided not to go for this as
this is why Nigel short really praised
Roger boss idea to sacrifice the knight
on e5 he said that casparo really hates
it when when he's on the attack if he
likes to be the one that has the
initiative so he short says that this
was actually a brilliant move by better
job of so okay after Knight G to e5
Kasparov played Queen tv3
now adding even more pressure here and
well after the knight moves this e six
pawn will fall but cuz rechak of plays
Knight to d7 and Kasparov captures the
pawn Queen captures on e6 we have Bishop
to h4 by a job of and Queen to g4 now
not allowing any rook to d8 ideas
resolve goes g5 and well this is already
a bit problematic for Kasparov you can't
capture this g5 point if you go Bishop
captures and g5 you get Rudy to g8 and
well your Bishop is trapped you're gonna
lose this bishop or or or you have to
give up this Queen for a bishop and the
rook so after g5 Casper has to play
Bishop to d2 and now Rock DTE eight is
played okay it's some breathing space
for Kasparov he has time to castle so he
plays it queenside castle and we have
Knight to a5 going
for that juicy be 3 square root D 2 F 1
is played and now Knight to b3 check
King to d1 and here is that problem that
Kasparov faced Raja who plays Bishop
captures and g3 and it's well it's a
very unpleasant unpleasant to move for
white if because part of captures this
Bishop for example H captures and g3 he
gets Queen to g6 with threats of Queen
to B 1 this would be devastating and
while you can't really you can't really
do much about this you can't for example
you can block with the Queen because
simply Queen captures on f5 and left to
rook captures recapture stun h1 as when
you captured the night with H capture
some g3 or you opened up the H file so
after a Bishop captures and g3 Kasparov
tries to go for some counter play he
plays rook to f7 now threatening Queen
captures on d7 but for job of simply
stops this rock to d8 and we have Bishop
captures and g5 now attacking that
rockin d8 Queen to g6 now is played and
again there's this threat of Queen to b1
and well this has to be stopped only
move as power of Ken plays Queen to f5
offering to trade Queens and the right
job of goes for this of course is up a
piece Queen captures rook captures and
rook D to f8 Raja Bob wants to exchange
even more pieces rook captures on f8
rook Knight captures on f8 and Bishop to
f3 this bishop can't be captured because
the world it's the pony still pinned now
he plays Bishop to f3
defending the rook and also attacking
this pawn on d5 so Bishop to h4 our Java
wants to exchange even more pieces
Bishop to e3 937 and Bishop captures on
d5 this is completely lost for casparo
but he tries a couple of more moves
we have rook to e8
Bishop to h6 Knight d2 c5 now you can
already see our jobs plan
Bishop to f7 rook to e7 Bishop to h5 and
night to d3 going for this b2 pawn and
also threatening a knight to have to
check for King the king and the rook and
well it was in this position that garry
kasparov didn't resign he just got up
from the board and he left the playing
hall so he pulled the bar to Laban
that's a good way to say it
and the well he lost in time Rajah Grove
had to wait for Kasparov's time to run
out and he was he was the winner of this
game and well Raja was awarded the
brilliancy prize for this game but
Kasparov didn't congratulate him or
anything he just left and what after
after the game when there was a warden
there was a press conference when they
awarded her a job of the brilliancy
prize Kasparov came back to the playing
hall and he took the microphone and he
gave us a 10 minute speech about how
this is a disgrace for chess and how
Raja was completely lost in that
position before before the knight
sacrifice which actually isn't true raja
baath could have simply played 92 h6 and
it would be completely fine for black
but raja baath decided to go for the
bold move sacrifice the knight and
completely crushed the world champion
but of course
well world champion as part of didn't
like this but yeah that's the game and
that's the story of how young or a job
of defeated world champion Garry
Kasparov in linearis of 2003 I hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon